auf der suche nach planeten wie jeder
bei der suche nach dem neunten planeten
in unserem sonnensystem helfen kann also
auch ich oder jeder von euch das erkläre
ich heute praktisch vom 25
herzlich willkommen es muss ein eis
planet sein er hat viel mal die masse
der erde und einen teil des vierfachen
er tragen müssen ist mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit klar dass
ein neunter planet weit draußen um die
sonne kreist es waren ja schon mal neun
doch dann hatte er fand die letzte
planet der pluto diesen status im jahr
2006 aberkannt bekommen schon vorher
waren lange darüber diskutiert worden ob
flut wirklich sowas wie ein planet ist
oder doch eher ein update heute rechnet
den status eines planeten neben ihm gibt
es noch viele andere objekte die mit ihm
vergleichbar sind und ebenfalls trump
neptunus sind das bedeutet dass sie
hinter dem letzten gasplaneten neptun
ihre bahnen in unserem sonnensystem
ziehen viele objekte die so weit von der
erde weg sind existieren zum teil nur
hypothetisch wird verschiedene
berechnungen können wissenschaftler
davon ausgehen dass es dort zwar
niedriger oder zumindest grob hämisch
körper gibt zum beispiel durch die
mögliche beeinflussung durch deren
gravitation auf andere planeten oder
aktuellen anhand einer
computersimulation verifizierten
forscher im jahr 2016 dass es dort noch
ein objekt geben muss da einige
phänomene nur durch gravitation eines
solchen großen planeten zu erklären wird
das wäre eben ein neunter planet nur
durch seine existenz lassen sich die
bewegung manche objekte im kupfergürtel
erklärt diesem rätselhaften noch immer
nicht bestätigten neunten planeten
möchte die nasa jetzt mit hilfe von
crowdsourcing auf die spur kommen
im rahmen des back york world kleinert
neuen projektes kann jeder der möchte
der nase helfen die daten des
weltraumteleskops wide field infrared
survey explorer oder clever ab griff
weiß nach dem neunten planeten
durchforsten man braucht also kein
teleskop keinen supercomputer oder
sonstiges es geht an jedem computer
smartphone oder tablet aktuell wird das
projekt von fast 19.000 freiwilligen
unterstützt insgesamt wurden schon mehr
als 100.000 objekte gesichtet und rund
80.000 davon
bereits von experten der nasa überprüft
bisher war aber noch kein neuer planet
dabei also ihr habt noch die chance für
ihn zu entdecken
die daten wurden auch erste hälfte
gesichtet es besteht also weiterhin die
möglichkeit einen neuen planeten oder
andere außergewöhnliche miss körper
aufzuspüren die tat bei fiat plant nein
hat das potential jahrhundert entdeckung
zu machen so auch in meißner von der
university of california in berkeley wer
jetzt lust bekommen hat sich an den
dichtungen zu beteiligen findet in der
video beschreibung den link zur aktion
schreibt er in die kommentare was ihr in
den aufnahmen vom reifen gefunden habt
und wie die arbeit mit den dateien ist
viel glück dabei und bevor er loslegt
rückt wir hier noch ein abo oft auge und
um nächste verfassung hat er mir auch
noch einen auf die glocke geben also
bestand